alors je vais vous montrer le standard
c'est de là que sont contrôlées les
départs en intervention avec une
personne qui a affecté en permanence
dans le département c'est la seule femme
à occuper cette fonction
valérie kern a pris le commandement du
centre de secours de vélizy villacoublay
en octobre 2015
une fonction à laquelle n'était pas du
tout destiné au départ j'ai un parcours
assez atypique parce que j'ai commencé
en tant qu ingénieur en informatique et
en tant qu ingénieur en informatique
parallèlement je suis rentré sapeurs
pompiers volontaires dans le département
de la savoie
c'est là où j'ai mis un pied dedans et
où j'ai commencé vraiment accroché pour
ce métier toutes les qualités humaines
et la rencontre avec les gens et donc
j'ai décidé d'en faire mon métier un
métier qu'elle exerce depuis 2008 dans
le 10 78 après avoir été affecté comme
officier de centre à montigny le
bretonneux
valérie est passé adjointe au chef de
centre de formation à trappes pour être
nommé trois ans plus tard chef du centre
de secours de vélizy-villacoublay toute
une partie administrative où on va gérer
le personnel consigne un sapeur pompier
professionnel que volontaire donc toute
une partie ressources humaines y aussi
la gestion
des formations en parallèle avec l'école
départementale
il ya aussi toute une partie de
relations avec les élus valérie est à la
tête d'une trentaine d'hommes et d'une
soixantaine de pompiers volontaires pour
une caserne qui effectue pas moins de
trois mille interventions par an sur le
secteur de vélizy jouy-en-josas et aux
loges en josas iphone à un exercice
d'entraînement donc
il simule un sauvetage d'une personne
qui seraient bloqués sur le toit il ya
un créneau horaire aux bouffes heures à
12 heures tous les jours donc ça qu'ils
se repentent à l'invention à fond leur
exercice
un poste rarement occupées par des
femmes en effet 90% des effectifs des
sapeurs pompiers sont des hommes
une fonction que valérie occupe
fièrement donc aujourd'hui je vais
remettre une attestation
de la parade ils colonisent écart d'un
directeur au chef farine qui a fait sa
formation je regarde des briefings
techniques post traumatique opérationnel
aujourd'hui remise de diplômes
un petit moment de plaisir au milieu de
toutes ces responsabilités et ben bonne
manoeuvre